on me dit que vous chantez oui mais non
ça j'arrête aussi
vincent daniel rire
chanter
les gens qui sont seuls si daniel
quelques bobos les bacs
ok tout le monde on a un champion on
regarde les caméras sur lui
c'est avec humour forcément qu'ils font
leur retour sur grand écran le duo du
palmashow signe les vedettes daniel et
stéphane son collègue tout les oppose
mais ils vont participer ensemble un jeu
télévisé objectif gagner de l'argent et
surtout briller en société un film sur
le besoin de reconnaissance et une
critique de notre temps
aujourd'hui on a en cours après les like
sur les réseaux sociaux après les gemmes
donc on fait un petit peu n'importe quoi
parfois on se rend ridicule on a envie
de passer à la télé dans l'été a hérité
les télé crochets courts après cette
reconnaissance est ce qui nous plaît
dans ce film c'était de raconter
justement une histoire d'amitié entre
deux types complètement en marge très
seul qui cherchent à s'intégrer de cette
manière mais qu'ils le font de façon
complètement ridicule mais qui par
chance vont se trouver
passage obligé à l'ugc ciné cité de
skywest de montigny le bretonneux pour
l'avant première les deux amis
originaires de montfort l'amaury on
tourner une partie du film au bréviaire
parodier la télévision un défi assez
simple pour le palmashow on essaie de
prendre des des émissions qui existe en
tout cas des mécanismes qui existent des
mécaniques des missions et après on y
glisse un peu notre humour différent un
peu à chaque fois
on essaie de garder une forme de
sincérité on peut être malgré tout pour
avoir de l'empathie d' pour n'importe
quel personnage je sais pas si vous en
avez conscience mais vous avez un énorme
potentiel
suffit pour peugeot et mention gresser
six ans après leur dernier film la fin
l'histoire de max et leon les vedettes
sortira dans les salles obscures ce
mercredi 9 février et en attendant le
palmashow a publié deux nouveaux
sketches autour de la promotion du film
sur leur chaîne youtube toute façon faut
qu'on s'occupe de la promo des vedettes
là il faut qu'on la déchire si on va
déchirer c'est quoi la première
interview